um so first I thought it might be
helpful to understand a little bit about
the organization
um cfar is the Canadian Institute for
advanced research we're a global
research organization based in Toronto
Ontario and Canada we bring outstanding
researchers from across disciplines and
borders together to identify and address
some of the most important Global
challenges facing science and Humanity
so for over 40 years we've been
advancing knowledge to create change in
society in industry and in government
across a range of cfar programs that
we'll take a peek at in a minute
okay
um see in terms of our approach it's a
fairly unusual model we take a long-term
view to supporting research programs and
research questions all of our programs
are problem oriented and we focus on
larger scale impact
over
incremental scientific advancements so
our programs operate on Five-Year
renewable terms currently with no Sunset
clause and we do that because we believe
that it does take time
um
four four programs to to develop a
shared sense of direction the kind of
trust and and reciprocity and
relationships
um to really
um Advance uh important goals our
programs meet in person two to three
times per year uh for meetings closed or
Invitation Only meetings of about two to
three days each
a program is comprised of approximately
when it's kind of all staffed up about
25 fellows again these are globally
distributed so really important to
understand this is not a residential
Fellowship
um fellows and Global Scholars remain in
Residence at their home institutions and
join a cfar program
um in this instance as a global scholar
for a period of two years
uh and uh we'll be talking a little bit
more about what all of these things mean
as we go forward
um but first I want to just uh again
take a take a look at kind of under the
hood and understand what cfar is so
looking ahead at
um uh our supporters uh cfar is funded
by a range of of different organizations
and institutions across government
across Canada's Federal and provincial
government the private sector as well as
through a host of different research
Partnerships at present cfar is
supported by the governments of Canada
Alberta and Quebec foundations
individuals corporations and Canadian as
well as International partner
organizations
all right so I promise we'd take a look
at our research programs now we have 15
programs in our research portfolio the
programs highlighted in red are
hopefully not surprising to anyone
joining us today the four that are
recruiting for cfar asriela Global
Scholars this year three of these are
our brand new programs having only uh
been started in April of this year so
that would be future flourishing
Humanities Urban future and the
multi-scale human and they are joined in
Good Company by gravity and the extreme
Universe a long-standing uh cfar program
that's recruiting
um it's I think third or fourth cohort
now of global Scholars
probably uh worth noting as well just as
we're talking about the programs that
all of our programs uh do take turns
um they they the recruiting Global
Scholars roughly speaking every other
year
um although there's some idiosyncrasies
there as well all right so what does it
mean to be a cfar azraeli global scholar
this is a unique opportunity to interact
to network and collaborate as I
mentioned already across disciplines and
geographies with World leading
researchers
uh in your own academic uh disciplines
or adjacent fields we view a critical
component of the global Scholars Program
being an opportunity to expand your
network and to interact with engage and
meet people with whom you wouldn't
ordinarily have the chance to work with
either at the standard set of academic
meetings that you go to perhaps because
you're an experimentalist and um and
they're a theorist for example but also
across the global Scholars cohort kind
of one of the things that we're really
looking to do is introduce cohorts of
early career researchers that are all
going through a similar experience at
the same time but in drastically
different fields um and yet and if there
is a shared shared experience
through the program you have access to
mentorship
from either the the senior fellows or
advisors in the program as well as
leadership and communication training
will more on that in a moment
um through the program you have the
opportunity to gain cross-sector
exposure if you're so inclined
um so there's a lot in the program that
that is going to be the same for
everyone but there's then a couple of
opportunities that I like to think of
more as sort of a Choose Your Own
Adventure so you can really self-guide
um to capitalize on the opportunity as
much as you have the bandwidth for
um through the program uh we believe
that Global Scholars are become well
positioned to be really influential
leaders and change agents both within
the academy but also outside
um uh in other Industries as well or
sectors
so moving on and taking a look at at who
can can apply and what our eligibility
criteria are in order to apply you must
hold a PhD or equivalent if you're in a
field where a PhD is not required to
have a faculty position
um uh and you're unsure if you're
just go ahead and reach out to us
um uh but uh but otherwise and let's
let's take a look at the other the other
criteria as well
um we say that you should be within the
first five years of a full-time position
at an institution of higher education
um or research
importantly what we're really looking
for here is that you have responsibility
for conducting an independent program of
research and supervising as well as
teaching trainees
uh who are working towards the
completion of a degree
uh if you've taken a leave of absence uh
for for any reason so maybe you're not
uh within those first five years anymore
again send us a note we'll take a peek
at your CV and confirm eligibility for
you
um we are ultimately looking to be as
inclusive as possible but within the
sort of the the parameters that we've
set out for the program
uh we expect candidates to engage in
research that complements the themes of
the goals of a recruiting cfar research
program this one is really important if
your research has nothing to do with any
of the four recruiting programs and you
see another cfar program that's a slam
dunk opportunity for you make sure that
you're signed up for our mailing list so
you can know when that program is
recruiting it is a fairly detailed
application process and I wouldn't
recommend that you apply just for the
sake of it if there's a program that
better suits your own research that will
be recruiting in a in a future year
we do expect
everyone who becomes a shortlisted
candidate be available to attend a
ritual interview between March 20th and
21st 2024. these dates are really
important and they're non-negotiable
unfortunately
um so if you are even thinking about
applying
um and you use a calendar why don't you
go ahead and Mark those dates off just
to make sure that you're available now
um uh and uh and there won't be any
problems
um should you be selected as a global
scholar it's really important that you
have a valid passport and be able to
obtain travel visa so if you are in a
kind of a precarious situation where you
can't leave the country where you are
for whatever reasons um maybe you're
waiting on a green card for example or
some other kind of long-term uh
permanent residence
um
talk to us and let's try and understand
kind of what what your constraints would
be before you decide whether you should
or shouldn't apply again we are here to
really help make sure that this is a
seamless process for you
um so ask as many questions as as you
have along the way
um we do expect
um uh participants to be fluent in
spoken and written English both our
selection process but also critically
our program meetings are conducted in
English
um and and so that's a pretty core
element of uh participation
um moving on to additional core
components of the program so we've
talked about eligibility now let's
understand what it is so I mentioned
earlier
um that you'd be applying directly to a
cfar research program
these are again interdisciplinary
collaborative networks they're totally
virtual networks everyone stays where
they are we bring you together for
in-person meetings two to three times
per year
um so you're applying directly to one of
those programs all of our programs as I
mentioned recruit on rotational basis as
a global scholar you'll have the
opportunity to focus uh on leadership
development training opportunities in
areas including and I'll get into
greater detail here in a minute
communication skills hiring and
retaining a research team and other
topics you'll also have the opportunity
to develop to develop new skills for
increasing the potential impact of your
work through engaging with non-academic
audiences as well as through identifying
and engaging with a mentor in your
selected program
what does it mean to participate in a
cfar research program
during your two-year term cfar Israeli
Global Scholars receive one hundred
thousand dollars
um Canadian in undesignated unrestricted
research support
uh really important to understand in
your uh application you're not writing a
grant proposal you don't have to tell us
what you're going to do with the money
as you would in a kind of a more
traditional cfp
um we are and we'll kind of we'll go
through the the core components of the
application in a moment
um to better understand the kinds of
questions that we're asking and what
we're looking for
you'll participate in a program meeting
I've mentioned this several times
already again you'll have the
opportunity to identify and select a
mentor from across our community of
fellows and advisors and I would say
that you can also include a request for
a mentor outside of your cfar research
program
uh if you are a truly interdisciplinary
scholar or have Ambitions to move in a
different direction and there's a just a
perfect fit across our Network in
another program we'd be more than happy
to make those introductions
um you'll also have the opportunity to
collaborate on new research with cfar
fellows and other Global Scholars either
in your own research program or across
other programs
through a seed funding opportunity
that we introduce very early on in the
program
there through the seafar azraeli global
Scholars Program we focus on
strengthening your leadership and your
communication skills topics explored
through Global scholar annual meetings
and through our virtual workshops which
occur throughout the year are identified
by global Scholars directly we do
regular pulse checks with our community
to understand their perceived needs and
the topics that they wish to explore in
addition to these group opportunities
you may also wish to pursue
self-directed experiences and we provide
additional funding and support to enable
you to do that
uh so during your two-year term you will
be invited and and we we hope that
you'll participate in an in-person
annual meeting as well as virtual
workshops which happen throughout the
year obviously there will be a virtual
uh workshop at some point that just
collides with your teaching schedule and
you miss it when we're able we um we do
record them and make them available to
our whole Community as well as learning
resources
through the leadership development fund
as I mentioned you'll also have the
opportunity to identify things that you
want to pursue on your own
um and uh foreign
and if there's something that that you
know a particular skill or an area that
that is important to you
um you should always feel that you could
come forward to us to ask
um for help uh finding that and and we
can you know do what we can to make it
happen
so moving along
um to the spring of 2024 uh we'll assume
that you've been selective Global
Scholars and we're uh approaching our
next leadership development uh
um Workshop that would be the the global
Scholars annual meeting that will be in
June of 2024 in Victoria British
Columbia we're anticipating hosting
um various sandpit sessions to
brainstorm new ideas for seed funding
across and between the global Scholars
community
uh there will be a media training
workshop at the annual meeting next
spring as well as opportunities to
strengthen and develop peer networks and
peer mentorship I think that's another
kind of critical component of the global
Scholars Program
uh and there will also be you know
optional uh other activities we try and
do you know an Excursion and um and just
kind of give give Global Scholars an
opportunity to explore
um the the surrounding area wherever we
are and again as I mentioned we'll be in
British Columbia next spring
um all right so I've mentioned a couple
times that we offer virtual Workshops
the virtual workshops are
um uh they they run throughout the year
on a variety of topics again these are
always identified by
um by the global Scholars Community
themes for the workshops that we've done
in the past have included managing your
science team uh setting goals giving
feedback and evaluating scientists
um uh and then something totally
different from that the art of effective
negotiation
um
leading leading scientific teams and
project meetings hiring and retaining
your team uh thinking Styles and
influencing Styles core principles of
data visualization
um as well as writing op-ed uh op-eds uh
we engaged a group called The op-ed
project who it was were absolutely
phenomenal resource for our Global
Scholars Community several of whom went
on to write op-eds and have them placed
in in local news newspapers
uh if so I wanted to give a little bit
of a sense of of what the kind of the
the inner person or the one-on-one
leadership development opportunities
might be so we offer leadership
development funds that Scholars can
access by sending a note to uh to the
global Scholars Program and saying I
really want to
um have editorial assistance on this
op-ed or on the manuscript
um or the prospectus that that I'm
working on before I send it off to a
publisher is that something you can help
me with absolutely
um and we've we already have a fairly
significant
database of opportunities but we're
finding that as Global Scholars have
more and more
um diverse needs um that that we're kind
of constantly building and looking for
new opportunities as well so in in North
America we've had several Global
Scholars participate in the faculty
success program if you're familiar with
that
as well as other kind of leadership
assessments um so several Global
Scholars recently have done 360
leadership assessments where members of
their kind of extended Network get uh
surveyed and then you go over the
results of that survey with a coach
um to learn more
um about about sort of what your
strengths and opportunities for growth
might be
um uh so moving on Beyond leadership
development I've mentioned once or twice
already that um a core component of the
program is is enabling Global Scholars
to increase their impact in and out of
Academia
um so in during your two-year term cfar
asraeli Global Scholars have the
opportunity to put the expertise the
leadership training directly into action
through participating in the
organization of summer and winter
schools
um uh I've mentioned several times
publishing op-ed's giving public
lectures
um maybe you've won an award that comes
with a public lecture and you want to
build a you know your own kind of social
media brand around yourself for the
first time in your career we can help
you do that as well
um so these are all examples of of ways
that you can kind of engage and start to
build impact beyond the kind of
scholarly uh um impact of of your
individual work
pardon me
all right so let's take a peek now
um at the the kind of the nuts and bolts
of the program
um so first and foremost if they're if
you are thinking about applying let's
all set a calendar reminder October 30th
11 59 PM pacific daylight time uh is is
the is is the the deadline
um applications must be submitted online
using our the application form
um and our online submission system
a a major uh component of our selection
process and something that runs
throughout the the application and
selection Is our commitment uh to EDI
see far
recognizes that and this kind of is part
and parcel of being a Global Network
um we recognize that bringing together
individuals from multiple and diverse
backgrounds perspectives and experiences
is integral to advancing excellence and
increasing the impact of our
organization
um and we do we ensure that that every
person who's a part of our Network feels
valued and welcome and is and that we
believe that this is vital to achieving
our mission it embodies our values of
diversity and creativity Excellence
risk-taking respect and collaboration
um we do try our hardest to include
those
um participants from underrepresented
groups in research and uh we also aim to
create a culture that embodies
um uh principles of equity diversity and
inclusion in all aspects of our work and
you'll see that running through the
application process
all right so what is the application
process uh there's a summary section uh
the summary should really present the
value that you anticipate from the cfar
Israeli Global Scholars experience aside
from the unrestricted money what is it
that you're most looking forward to to
being a part of this network
you'll provide a brief statement about
the three areas of leadership or
communication that you most wish to
strengthen
this is the first time
um out of many that you get to tell us
the areas that you're interested in
exploring through leadership development
we'll ask you to provide a brief
statement about how your skills and
knowledge will contribute to advancing
our commitments to EDI
and we'll ask for a short description of
your research interests using lay terms
for a general audience
uh moving on from the summary section in
our detailed section
um we will ask you to to provide a
discussion of your research background
your proposed future directions this is
not again as I mentioned intended to be
a grant proposal you're really talking
about how you complement the research
program that you're applying to where
there are synergies maybe there are gaps
that you think are fundamentally
important to the conversation that the
program is trying to have that is your
place to tell us about those
we're looking for a discussion of how
you've engaged with non-academic
communities or how you want to engage
with non-academic communities to extend
the impact of your research
and hopefully coming is no surprise we
ask for an up-to-date copy of your CV
um including a full publication list uh
critical to note that you do have to to
upload this as a PDF and it literally
has to say dot PDF it's a little
idiosyncrasy of our of our process
um you'll want to make sure that that
that happens
um uh to to avoid any problems down the
line when you go to submit
um looking ahead as well uh the
application does include letters of
reference it critical also to note your
application must include the required
recommendation letters directly
submitted by your referees before it can
be submitted as final
um you have to arrange to have the
letters of recommendations submitted to
your online application you'll insert
somebody's email address they'll get a
request
um they should be able to log on without
incident if and when someone has a
problem they can come to us and we'll
help them
um the one notable exception if you're
asking a cfar program member so a fellow
an associate fellow or an advisor who's
a current member of the program that
you're applying to to provide a letter
then your application must include three
letters we will only accept three
letters from someone who has one of the
three as a
a current program member if you and if
you have three uh referees none of which
are members we will only accept the
first two
so there is no benefit to having three
letters submitted on your behalf
um unless you do fall into that
exception category
um
when you're thinking about who you want
to ask uh to write your letters or which
letter writers to ask probably uh the
better way of thinking about it
um think about
um someone who's well positioned should
speak to both your scholarly academic
achievements so research Excellence
productivity your creativity and breadth
of your interests as well as your
demonstrated leadership capacity
um moving on from letters of a
recommendation and
and this is this is something that comes
up every year with a handful of
candidates
um if you have a pending first full-time
eligible position starting uh no later
than July 1st 2024
um but you haven't yet started
we will ask you to upload a copy of of
um of your appointment letter to your
application uh and we do that just
really to to make sure that you are
eligible to apply
um all right so moving ahead let's look
at the review processing criteria and I
promise I'm almost done here
um so as I've mentioned several times we
are strongly committed to equity
diversity and inclusion at each stage of
the application review and selection
process committees consider cfar's
principles of EDI
and and
we've also partnered with a third party
firm to collect demographic information
on all of our applicants
and as I've mentioned previously as
fluency in English is required fully to
participate in our programs our our both
our application process as well as the
selection meeting happen in English
our application review process
starts with a basic eligibility check
and we'll look to make sure that each
recruiting program has elected a
subcommittee of program members
typically on the order of three to four
members whose research areas and
background and expertise as well as
geography spans the breadth of the
program
their job is to review the research
Excellence potential to contribute to
the program and the leadership potential
of the applicants each program selection
committee recommends up to five
shortlisted finalists who will be
invited to attend the virtual interview
in March which you all already put into
your calendars
that final selection meeting which
happens on March 20th and 21st and is
for the the up to 20 across the four
recruiting programs shortlisted members
interviews are conducted by an
independent and diverse Committee of
academic researchers experienced leaders
in areas such as policy or government
Communications and leadership
development there there may be cfar
advisors or program members former
Global Scholars on that committee but
none of them will be from programs that
are currently recruiting the final
selection is completely separated from
and walled off from the the recruiting
programs
the selection committee evaluates
candidates on their communication skills
their capacity and motivation to engage
with peers across disciplines and their
potential leadership and impact
foreign
part of the reason that we um that we
give the dates for the interview in
advance is that there is a
um there there is both an individual but
also a group component to the interview
process because we are looking for how
people engage
um across and uh and between our
Networks
some other key dates as well uh that you
may wish to note one of which amazingly
is now a week in the rearview mirror uh
the call for applications opened last
week on August 30th so that means you
should all be able to download all of
the full materials if you want to work
offline it closes on October 30th
again at 11 59 pacific daylight time uh
by January 31st of next year short we
anticipate that shortlisted finalists
will have been notified uh two have
their virtual meeting an interview
scheduled on March 20th and 21st for
final notification we are hoping before
the end of March 2024.
so for more information you can download
the detailed program Overview at c4.ca
Global Scholars and you can contact us
and our email address is there on the
screen I want to thank you so much for
sticking with it I I know I'm a bit a
bit long-winded here
um and we're gonna move ahead into
um into breakout groups looking forward
to to talking further in a minute thanks
everyone
thank you